so what is testosterone do well most
people think our testosterone the sort
of common misconception is it's our own
makes you violent an aggressive okay
that's not actually what testosterone
testosterone causes you to seek status
it's the status seeking hormone now it
turns out that being aggressive and
violent a certain percentage of the time
works to help you get status so that's
why people have but that's where there's
a common misconception but what it does
is it causes you to seek status and why
do men have 20 times a testosterone in
women because they're having a higher
social status because a polygamy pays
off for men more than it does for women
okay one man many wives is much more
common than one wife for many men and
has been throughout a revolutionary
history so there's a much higher status
payoff for men in reproductive terms
than or for women the reason for that by
the way is because women are taken out
of the reproduction game yeah for nine
months right and men are taken out the
reproduction game for 10 seconds and so
for your sake you need a nap afterwards
so in terms of your sex ratio yeah yeah
absolutely
you know that's why men seek states will
have high levels of testosterone so you
know I'm not telling you anything you
don't know everybody knows that men
particularly when they're 17 to 25 are
just puffing yeah that's what that's
what they do they peacock you know yeah
and that's not a only is a social cliche
and the reason social cliche is because
there's a hormonal basis forever so is
that to say that there are no aspects of
say misogynistic behavior that aren't
learnt no of course there are aspects of
misogynistic behavior that are learnt
but there is also you know genes times
environment there's also a heritage
component and an inherited component of
this for the vast vast vast majority of
males on the planet ok now come back to
this other idea of like unconscious
versus conscious right that's a tussle
within our brains and of course you can
bring up boys for example in a way that
recognizes that they have 20 times on
average the levels of showing the girls
do which means they will chest puff and
they will peacock and they will do those
things and so you can bring boys up with
that knowledge and this you know there's
why men are risk takers for instance and
I just think you need to come back to
this idea of why aren't we talking about
this in politics it's not helpful to say
toxic masculinity is a learnt behaviour
and we all need to bring upon children a
gender-neutral way right which I don't
pass any comment on I'm just saying
that's one of the arguments where
actually I think it would be much more
beneficial to say okay there are
actually these differences between men
and women and so we can we can construct
our society in in a very clever way that
gets to the ultimate goal if we agree
that we all want to get to complete
equality between the sexes I find that
it would be much better way to get to
that eventual goal if we say these are
the differences and therefore we
deconstruct our society to get to that
point rather than saying no there are no
differences it's all learn you know to
know to get to where you want to get to
you have to know where you are yeah yeah
and if you think you're in the wrong
place you're not going to get to where
you get where you want to get to
you
[Music]